um I think some people who aren't from
the bay might not understand the gravity
of Mac Dre right I think that for a lot
of people
Mac Dre wasn't a thing until he passed
and that's how they found out about him
now obviously in in the bay he's a lot
different but I had heard prior to him
passing he was more embraced by like the
like more nerdy like like Berkeley like
rap hippie [__] like explain to me kind
of the dynamic of Mac Dre like and his
kind of career and how things change in
in the way he was perceived after he
passed even even from like somebody like
yourself I think even the misconception
of Berkeley like we we people graph
Berkeley from Telegraph street and they
think that that's just Berkeley like
Berkeley is Hood like you know what I'm
saying it's right you got the South
Berkeley's the waterfronts like so
all Berkeley not just what you see on
Telegraph street like if San Berkeley is
like a it's a real spot like it's a hood
spot so
um his fans though to you know support
what you were saying he had a fan base
um before he before he got out of jail
like people forget the California living
people forget the too hard for the radio
on his first run right where he sold you
know hundreds of thousands of Records
um and is it safe to say that was before
the Fizz face for sure way before that
then you know he went to the federal
penitentiary
um for trumped up charges and he refused
to uh tell on his friends he did about
five and a half years and he came out
and his philosophy was man I'm just
gonna have fun right I'm gonna just kick
it make some party music and chill and
Miami
created you know the term this and it
was just about just having fun like
doing the hippie like creating the the
modern day hip-hop hippie right and uh
a lot of people don't understand
he went I won't say under the wing but
let's say side by side with Andre
Nickatina and nicotine was like who's
another Legend who doesn't super icon
who you won't get an interview out of
you want anything
um but still does like random shows yeah
he'll do he when he wants to yeah you'll
be like 100 nicotine is performing here
like he's doing this he's doing this
thing now with the symphony where
they're doing he's like the San
Francisco Symphony is doing his music
and like Nikki's I think gazi was
telling me about that I love Nikki like
like Nikki is the dude where he's a he's
a guru man he'll he talked to you in
Parables and it's just like you sit up
and he'd be like
see all that [__] just miss me being a
kid from Phoenix like the Mac Dre Andre
Nickatina I was listening to E40 in a
major way I was listening to all the two
short [__] so they were underground like
hieroglyphics but like and and like uh
Sally cell [__] like that but that like
underbelly dog was like Dre Dog is you
know that's nicotine that's like the
under undercut so Dre and Dre and Dre
hooked up so nicotina and and
and uh Mac Dre hooked up
and Dre was like I'm gonna introduce you
to these other fans
to these fans that's supportive to these
fans that's going no matter what you do
right and we went out on tour and it was
a nicotina tour
and me I was like
I thought
Mac Dre was bigger than Nikki right
until I went to the Seattles and the
olympias and the Salems and the the
bellinghams and I was like oh it's
different he's bringing him out yeah
like Nikki huge so I got a chance to go
on a Canadian tour with nicotina and I
was just I was blown away because I'm
like we're going in the cities you can't
I can't even pronounce the city and I'm
just like the lines wrapped around the
corner and like nicotine is just like
wow so that's the fan base they had they
had like you know big shout outs to
Santa Rosa Sebastian pool Petaluma Ukiah
humble all of these small cities that
people bypassed the normal mainstream
hip-hop they go right by those these
cities but these guys made a career off
showing love to those fans right and um
until this day those fans are very still
supportive man and and that's the bay
area's chitlin circuit where they go
yeah that's real it's like you get kind
of that whole you could go to Boise
from from Seattle to San Diego and then
we jump over because of course we go to
Arizona we go Boise and from that area
that whole little that chitlin circuit a
Bay Area an artist
can make a living
and now two and a good one and now La
artist it's the same time most
definitely most definitely because the
sound is similar yeah because the LA
[__] like I'll notice like guys like you
know I'm always trying to talk to some
of my friends and be like hey you know
like how do we get past get you past
Arizona or get you past Albuquerque
right you know what I mean right because
that's really the key a kid named Kailyn
for real for real did a good job because
he just moved to Atlanta for like a year
he went crazy when he came to the Bay
yeah so like but he went to the South
and try to break there first and it kind
of worked in his favor because you know
now he can go to Atlanta and do a show
but I do think that chitlin circuit is a
real thing yeah you have you have to tap
into the chilling circuit because
something that people lack nowadays that
they allow social media to confuse them
into thinking just because you have
followers that you have fans true and
that's a difference fans break bread
they'll buy the shirt followers like
nosy neighbors right your followers are
the people that just want to look and
they peek through the window they sure
won't want but the difference between
followers and fans are those fans are
going to say dude I'm going I want I
want that picture I want to be I want
that autograph memorable here's a tattoo
by the way Hey listen right you know I
need that you know and then that fan is
they're going to subscribe to your tribe
and that's how you become successful
that's how somebody passed the
Mississippi may not have never heard of
Mr Fab or
Pastor Rockies may not have never heard
of Mr fab right but you come to our area
and you're like wow you you have all of
these entities and you have this
influence and you you ride around town
and Lamborghinis and Maseratis you do
all of these things you know all of the
things that they're in all by right but
it's because we wouldn't be anything
without the fans and so our chitlin
circuit
is uh it's very impactful and thriving
especially if you go out and you involve
yourself and dedicate with them
so why do you think uh and I might be
wrong but was Mac Dre more embraced by
the inner city after he passed or was
his influence recognized more once he
passed away in terms of just kind of
like the hyphy movement and like what
kind of came after his death because I
feel like after Mac Dre passed away is
really when
the haifi movement took on a whole new
level and I can you know obviously you
can give a lot of credit to a lot of
people but I think my get a report card
is kind of what brought the hyphy move
into the world
um but like why do you think that his he
wasn't maybe necessarily appreciated as
much as he is now
um
because I I I've never been the guy I'm
not like I've never been a Big Mac Dre
fan so I try to understand that because
I go to the Bay I'm like God damn it
this [__] I went and bought a
Mac Dre soda in Vallejo you know what
I'm saying it's
A hip-hop fan who's never heard
A J dilla beat who would argue that Jay
Dill is one of the best producers ever
I just had this kid cash kid from
Detroit who's from Detroit and I said
have you ever heard of Jay Dillon and he
was like oh what's that I was like so
like it's just it's just like
what comes with
the post
it's people just automatically begin to
give you
a certain amount of Praise or they
continue just because they feel and
that's unfortunate because I think we
just saw it with Nipsey most definitely
like the world stopped when Nipsey died
and it was like where were these people
at when nips was alive for sure like you
know now give it credit that there were
a lot of people that loved Nick for sure
but was it like that right right right
you know what I'm saying was it was it
like that it's almost like he had to to
be fully appreciated for everything he
was doing it's like there seldom do you
see artists get a chance to receive that
love while they are alive right
um I think Mac Dre was able to receive
that and
the world that he was in right he was
able to feel that
um he dropped the DVD called Trill TV
and and this is just being and
transparency people in Oakland was just
like okay that's Vallejo That's The Romp
that's that's them that's they doing
their thing they wasn't really super
crazy Mac Dre fans Not the majority of
course you have fans that were already
previous fans uh you know in the
formation of what we talked about right
uh
but when Trill TV came out and people
was like
bro that's how you living right like
Trill TV showed him an effect where he
had G-Wagon he had the Platinum chain he
had to grill he was like it he became a
superstar right
and for a long time the Bay Area hadn't
saw that they hadn't saw somebody in the
benzes and and the things that he had
the chains and the watch and they was
like oh this
Cuddy this [__] Saucy he like I want to
be him like I'm saying now people want
to they they started
aspiring to be like him the lifestyle so
that gave him a level of star power that
you know it it was it was an avalanche
and
on his incline unfortunately what took
place took place so he was he was Rising
back up on the end and so that momentum
still pushed forward after he passed and
people were just like bro y'all yeah
y'all seen that but y'all didn't get a
chance to see it so it became folklore
it was like folklore it was it was Urban
folklore it was like y'all didn't get a
chance to see it yep we was there like
we saw ma like people tell you their
stories of his star power you know I'm
saying it's like you know Jesus people's
got to talking about we don't know if
those stories was true it's like man for
real he touched the [__] man and he
cure leprosy man and yeah well he took
the bread and cut the fish up and fed
everybody was like you know the folklore
begins to expand and so that's what it
was with Dre but if you asked me was he
able to feel or smell those Roses I do
believe that he was because he was able
to see his impact and how impactful that
it was becoming in his Resurgence and
unfortunately it was cut short
um
40 and Warner did a hell of a job with
packaging up
the hyphy movement and selling it right
shout out to Little John too the most
definitely that was the Hall of the you
know Warner Little John tvt 40 they did
a great movement in pushing it forward
and a lot of people capitalized off of
it
um from you know monetary perspective
right but I feel like the whole
package of seeing it all if they would
have got a chance to see it all it it
would have been amazing like if you
would have got a chance to see Too Short
40 Mac Dre key right you know and then
the younger Federation the team Fabs and
turf talks and all the other guys that
played a significant role in keeping
that snowball going into an avalanche I
think he would have got a chance to see
uh it being broader and being more spoke
about rather than just the folklore of
what it was and what it could have been
hmm